- I am currently conducting
a training program
for a large UK company, on
how to communicate effectively
in a business environment,
and especially regarding
your slide writing skills,
regarding how you set up
professional business presentations,
for instance, in PowerPoint.
And one of the things I've
had most people struggle with
is how to adapt my
presentation to my audience.
And not only regarding my
personal communication style,
but also regarding how I set up my slides,
how I set up my pages in
the presentation software.
In this video, we're going
to talk about exactly that.
I'm going to talk about
a very powerful framework
that can help you adapt
your communication style
to your audience, and we're
going to discuss different types
of business documents and
how these different documents
need to be adapted to be a
good fit to your audience.
Hi guys. My name is Heinrich.
Welcome to another Coffee
Break with Firm Learning.
Hope you're all enjoying
the weekend and got yourself
a great coffee as I just did.
For those of you watching
for the first time
this channel Firm Learning is all about
making you successful in the
first years of your career.
And one of the topics I like
to frequently talk about here
are technical skills.
Are the technical skills like PowerPoint,
How you can step up your
PowerPoint game to the next level,
because the truth just is in
most business organizations,
tools it's like PowerPoint
are frequently used,
and it's just super important,
especially as a young professional
just to master these tools
and to perform with these tools well.
So as I announce in the beginning,
today is going to be all about
how to adapt your
message to your audience.
And if you're taking any value
out of this video at all,
please Hit the Like button
for the YouTube algorithm.
And also Hit the Subscribe button
to not miss any of the
videos I'm releasing
every single week.
And if you want to see even more from me
also follow me on my Instagram.
My handle is @firmlearning
and I also have a mailing list
where I share regular tips and tricks
on how to be successful in the
first years of your career.
So if you're interested in that
there's a link in the video description
to this mailing list as well.
But now without further
ado, let's jump into it.
How can you tailor your communication,
your presentations
better to your audience.
Just to kick this off, I just
want to briefly talk about
why it is even necessary
to tailor your message
to your audience.
And in the business context,
it is easy to recognize
that you are being confronted
with all kinds of communicative settings.
You might sit together with your team
and talk about the progress
of your individual work,
for instance, directly with your team lead
or you're having a jour-fixe
with members of other teams
of other departments, cross functions,
or even presenting in front
of your senior management.
Maybe in front of your board members.
And I hope it is obvious that
of course the expectations
of your board members,
will be very different
than the expectations
of your direct teammates
and what you need to say
and how you need to communicate
that with highly differ
based on who you talk to,
based on whom your audience is.
So let's start by talking
about a basic framework
which helped me to understand
what the different factors at play are,
what I might need to look out for
to understand how I
should adapt my message.
And this basic framework is called
the communication triangle.
And based on this communication triangle
there are things that
you need to be aware of
that you need to take into consideration
when you want to frame
and adopt your message
in the right way.
And the first dimension of this triangle
is your personal style or
even your company culture.
Of course, not all presentations
need to look the same.
It can differ.
Whether it's you presenting
or somebody else.
Everybody brings his own
personal style to the table.
And yes, it is completely fine
and completely appropriate
to let your presentation be influenced
by your personal style, by
your way of handling things.
And on one level further
beyond your personal style,
of course, there's also such
a thing as company culture.
Probably if you work for instance,
one of the GAFA companies
such as Facebook,
the way the communication is
done will be very different
than for instance, in one of
the old school tech companies
like Siemens in Germany.
So ask yourself, what is
the culture that I am in,
and also ask yourself,
what is your personal style
that you want to bring to the table?
And then yes, this is the first dimension
of you asking yourself, how you wanna go
about presenting the message
that you want to present.
But of course, in a business
setting, there's more to it
than just your personal style.
Because there is such a thing
as an objective occasion
that you'll put yourself in.
There are different types
of objective occasions
and as per these different occasions,
there are certain rules
that are just expected
that people will follow
if they put themselves
in these occasions.
And now again, you can
differentiate between
sitting in a boardroom, sitting
together with board members,
and presenting something to them.
Or just sitting with
your direct colleagues
or maybe with an intern
that you supervise,
and you want to present a
couple of ideas to your intern.
These are all different
objective occasions,
and the way that you present your message,
the way that you communicate
should be influenced by
this objective occasion.
So again, always ask yourself,
what is your objective occasion
that I'm now putting myself into?
And what likely are the expectations
that are surrounded by
this objective occasion
that you're putting yourself into.
Now the third dimension are
the audience expectations.
Even within one objective
occasion or within one company,
the audience expectations,
the expectations of the different members
that you are going to talk
to, will be different.
And just one basic example
from my experience.
Now looking at this bottom setting,
are the expectations of
different board room members,
how beautiful, for
instance, PowerPoint pages
need to be made.
So is it fine to just
copy a table for instance,
from an excel sheet into your presentation
and present that to your board members?
I've seen many large companies
where many board members
are completely fine with that,
and this is completely
meeting the expectations.
But then I've also seen other companies
where board members just expect
that in the board meetings,
people really do an effort
of making all pages look
beautiful, designing them properly,
and really beautifying all these pages.
So ask yourself now
independent from your culture,
your personal style, or
the objective occasion,
what will be the
expectations of the people
that you meet, when you sit together,
when you hold your presentation,
and then also take this into consideration
when you're adopting a style.
Now that we have an understanding
of the different factors
in play about how to tailor your message,
let's think about the typical
documents that you create
and how these considerations
impact these documents.
And let's start by talking about
a simple team alignment document.
What I envision here is now a setting
where you sit together
with your teammates,
maybe your direct team lead
and you're having a discussion
some kind of an alignment
in your personal work,
maybe you need some
decisions, from your teammates
or some other things
you'd like to talk about,
sitting together and
presenting a basic document.
What's important with these documents
is that you should
rather just be as brief,
as concise as simple as possible.
In most settings, don't
waste too much time
for creating beautiful pages.
There is no need to create
elaborated storylines.
So maybe you've seen some of my videos
on good slide writing principles.
While these are highly relevant
to many of the other
document types we are going
to talk about in a minute.
Don't waste your effort
and energy on that.
This document types will be just be about
just having an efficient quick meeting
with your team members.
Just putting a few ideas
on a piece of paper
and not wasting too
much time thinking about
the whole presentation and
making beautiful pages.
The second type of documents are so called
jour-fixe documents.
And of course, here it might
change quite significantly
company by company, what
exactly jour-fixe is,
how this is handled, what
type of people sit in.
And so please adjust that
based on these factors.
But in general jour-fixes
are used to sit together
with people also from other
teams, other departments
other functions and align on the progress
on certain projects or
other important initiatives
that you are working on.
And here, I still believe
that the focus should not be
too much about creating beautiful pages.
These should be rather
very hands on meetings
where you sit together
with the people aligning
and just getting the perspectives.
Though in contrast to these documents
that just stay in your team in
the safe space of your team.
With jour-fixe documents like that
here, quality is now much more important
for the reason that these documents
will be easily sent
around the departments.
Other people might see
and read these documents
who weren't even sitting in the meeting.
And here it's not very easy
quick to just confuse people.
If your pages are not set up properly,
if your pages do not follow
good slide writting practices,
then you will have very quickly problem
and people will be confused.
And this might even create
some political issues
in your company, in your organization,
if you don't work it in the right way.
So if you want to know more about
what these good slide
writing principles are
that I would highly recommend you,
I have a whole playlist on
this channel with videos
that I created on this topic,
I will link it somewhere above here.
So check that out for these
good slide writing practices.
And if you're really serious
to improve your slide creation game
and create business presentations
that follow the standards
of top consulting firms
such as BCG or McKinsey,
I created a whole online
course on the topic.
I have over 10,000 students
already taking that course.
So if you believe this is something
that might interest you as well,
I have a discount link to the course
in the video description below.
So feel free to check it out.
There's also lots of student
reviews for you to read
to better understand.
One final tip that I have for you
regarding these Jour Fixe documents,
make sure that in the beginning,
when you set up a Jour Fixe,
you will line on a basic agenda
with the other members of the Jour Fixe
so that you already have a skeleton
for the document aligned.
And you don't need to think about
every time we have these
weekly jour fixes from scratch,
how you structure it, what the things are,
that you should put into it.
Next, this board-level type of documents
or other types of documents
that you are going to present
in front of senior leadership
of your organization.
Here now all these slide writing
and story lining principles
that are talked so much about
and all these other videos
and also my online course,
this is where you really need to nail it.
This is where this is so important.
Just put yourself into the
shoes of the board member
of a large blue chip company,
you will likely have 20,
30, 40, 50 projects going on
in parallel.
All these initiatives, all
these teams he's responsible for
and that are regularly
presenting updates to him.
It is so easy to get completely derailed
in these kinds of meetings
for little minor details
and how your presentation is structured
for little in accuracies on your pages.
He'll be super diligent
when you create your
document to really meet
first the objective occasion
of these kind of meetings,
but then also the expectations
that many of these senior managers...
many of these senior leaders will have.
When I worked at McKinsey,
one of the partners used to tell me,
"Heinrich when you
present at board meetings,
you to see to keep it
as simple as possible.
Use very basic language.
Do not use any fancy
complicated technical terms,
use high font sizes on your page.
Don't use very little nitty-gritty text
that nobody's going to read anyway,
keep it simple and to the point
and this is then where you will win
in these kinds of meetings."
Next are documents that
are created for an external audience.
For instance, and Investor Relations
or if you sit together with
your banks, lending institutions
or any other occasion
where external stakeholders
are involved.
And here, I believe that the principles
that you need to apply are very close
to what is expected in
the board level setting.
Meaning that of course,
you should hold yourself
to the highest quality
standards out there.
But on top of that, be aware
that these external documents
often have legal implications.
For instance, if you work
in the finance department,
you need to be very careful
what claims you make
around the liquidity of your company,
especially maybe if your company
is in a tough financial
position at the moment.
So make sure that you
consult with your legal team,
with your PR team with
all the other experts
that you have in your organization
to make sure that your documents
meet these higher standards.
And last but not least,
let's talk about documents
that are mainly used for documentation.
So these are documents which
may never get presented,
but it's rather about
documenting certain things,
how things work, how certain
processes are set up.
And what's of course important here
is not to really get into the details
and be super specific and detailed.
In contrasting that with board
level style of presentations
where you use very high font sizes
where you try to not get
too much into the details,
where you try to not get too complicated
with these documentation documents,
of course, it's going to be lots of text,
of course, you're going
to use lots of words,
you're going to make a very
detailed and very specific
because this is what this
document is all about.
And here even more important
than with other documents
is that this document
needs to stand for itself.
And what this means is
that maybe if somebody
one year from now or two years from now
picks up this document,
and maybe all the members
who worked on the document
in the first place
are not in the organization anymore.
And this person is able to understand
everything thing out of
the document in itself
without anybody needing
to stand next to it
and to explain it to him.
So the document needs to stand for itself,
needs to be self-sufficient
in the way that information is presented.
So these were my thoughts
on how you adapt your presentations,
your documents to your audience,
very much hope this makes sense.
Let me know in the comments below
what your opinion is.
Whether you have any questions,
I'll do my best to answer
every single comment
that you write.
Again, if you took any value
out of the video though,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to my channel
and also turn on the notification bell
to make sure that you're really informed
about every single video
because otherwise YouTube
might not show my videos
even if you subscribe to the channel.
If you wanna follow me on my Instagram,
my handle is firmlearning.
And also don't forget to sign
up to my e-mail newsletter
if you wanna hear even more from me.
Thanks for watching guys. I
really appreciate your time.
I hope that I delivered
value to you with this video.
Next one is going to come
next Saturday as every week.
So looking forward to that
and until then good weekend
to all of you. Cheers guys!